to say that relations between russia and
the west have soured in the 21st century
would be accurate but it would not do
justice to the real threat that we tend
to no longer want to see
as the u.s pivots more and more to asia
the rivalry between washington and
beijing leaves little oxygen for any
conflicts between washington and moscow
and yet the explosive potential remains
and if anything it shows no signs of
easing
take a listen to what the head of
russia's foreign intelligence service
said last week about the menace of
western liberal values
the united states of america and other
western countries continue their
attempts to export their totalitarian
liberal values in the space of the
commonwealth of independent states
we propose dedicating today's event to
countering the modern hybrid forms of
the west's destructive interference in
the internal politics of our countries
those are clear strong words my first
guest tonight is more qualified than
almost anyone to give a realistic read
on where the troubled relationship
between russia and the west is headed in
her new book there is nothing for you
here fiona hill takes us from her
english roots to those roots that she
planted herself in the united states a
transatlantic life in korea that has
made her one of the authorities in the
western world
on russia
fiona hill joins me tonight from
bethesda maryland ms hill it is good to
have you on the program there is so much
that we want to talk with you
about tonight i'd like to start though
by getting your thoughts on what has
happened this week with russia basically
saying that they're done trying to work
together with nato
well unfortunately there's been quite a
lot of
events that have precipitated this uh
that have led up to this point um just a
week or so ago nato expelled
several russians from the russian
mission uh to nato there for
inappropriate behavior malign activity
there's always been some considerable
tension in that uh effort between nato
and russia to find a murderous operandi
i mean we recall that you know back in
the 90s we even flirted with the idea of
having russia join nato in some form
that was then replaced by a nato russia
council
where we were supposed to be creating a
forum for airing grievances and having
discussions about how we might work in
the future but russia has always wanted
to have a veto over nato activities he
didn't accept that um there was a place
in nato for it because it still saw nato
in a cold war or context and there's
just been this constant back and forth
back and forth of tensions and uh mutual
recriminations and i think you know at
this point after the expulsion of uh the
the russian members of uh the mission
there that russia is doing you know one
of its classic uh retaliatory actions
and you know basically by declaring an
end to this letters affairs in the
relationship
let's talk about you for a moment you
are a coal miner's daughter from the uk
who has lived the american dream you
went to harvard became a russian
specialist worked at the u.s national
security council became an advisor to a
u.s president
yet in your book
you write this i am a fluke my story is
the exception that proves the rule of
class or socio-economic immobility in
the early 21st century
how so
well i could have said the same about
the 20th century as well because that's
actually when i started most of my
career rise but i think you know we're
seeing more and more in western
societies uh in the united states the
united kingdom where i'm from you know
and to some degree in germany and other
countries too that
education is no longer the door uh to uh
opportunity for a job or a career
uh that it used to be and in fact in the
united states in particular now
education either finishing high school
or going on to further education into a
university
has become more of a predictor of how
you will vote and how you look at the
world than anything else it's kind of
become the new class dividing line
whereas i uh myself you know from uh
basically growing up in the united
kingdom what i did in the 60s 70s and
80s had every advantage of uh of an
education opening up doors uh for the
future and i think that you know
obviously in places like germany you
know for example education has still got
a very strong emphasis but increasingly
in the united states and in the united
kingdom there's kind of an expectation
that social mobility will no longer come
through education as it did before so
education again is this big this new
dividing line uh for our societies and
is having political implications
yeah and you are worried about the
future of liberal democracies but
especially the future of the united
states you also write in your book that
the current political poison if you will
will keep on empowering the political
extremes reinforcing the polarizing
appeal of populist politicians and you
say it will make the traumas of the four
years from 2016 to 2020 seem like a
preface rather than a postscript to the
united states democratic demise
ms hill you're very worried about donald
trump becoming u.s president again in
2024 would that be an apocalypse now for
the u.s
well unfortunately we're already in uh a
major constitutional crisis i mean i
don't think it's really a
the the viewers of deutsche bala that
president trump uh claims that the
election was stolen from him in november
2020 he has uh refused to recognize joe
biden many of uh members of the
republican party have done the same as
the legitimately elected president
and uh basically donald trump is
insisting uh on you know running again
as the candidate for the republican
party in 2024
he's accused all kinds of questions
about um the uh
validity of not just the presidential
election but the whole electoral system
democracy overall i mean you're showing
images here of um president trump
meeting with vladimir putin and you know
i write in the book that trump has taken
out in many respects some of the
authoritarians handbook uh there's an
effort underway to try to repress voting
in the united states deny voting to
people to make it much more difficult
there's the nationalization of politics
of the local and state level which we
didn't used to see in the united states
and the biggest problem right now is the
big lie
about uh the ninth the 2020 election and
also what happened on january 6 in the
united states where i'm sure it was very
shocking for deutsche weller and other
viewers to see a mob storming the us
capitol building and trying to stop the
legitimate transfer of executive power
and the certification of the the votes
from the 2020 election and and that mob
was even threatening to hang vice
president pence um who was doing his
constitutional role in certifying the
election i mean it's been a shocking
last several months
and more than a year now i think for
most observers outside of the united
states let's learn for those of us
inside yeah i think for people looking
from outside it's shocking to think that
the future of the united states may
definitely include donald trump
once again
what about the future
for vladimir putin this is what he
recently said when he was asked about
his plans beyond 2024 when his current
presidential term ends take a listen
yeah
i prefer not to answer these questions
this is my traditional response
there's plenty of time before the next
elections
conversations like this destabilize the
situation
it is hard to imagine russia without the
the imprint of vladimir putin for the
foreseeable future
the country belongs to him it seems
until when
well until he decides to uh hand it over
to a successor that he would presumably
handpick
or of course unless you know faye takes
a hand and this is
uh you know deeply destabilizing and
dangerous for russia putin himself when
he moved away from the presidency after
his first two terms and handed over to
uh dimitri medvedev his close associate
back in
2007 2008 said it was very destabilizing
and very dangerous for all power to be
in the hands of one man well that's been
quite some time ago now and he has
essentially constitutional amendments in
2020 made it entirely possible for him
to stay in the presidency until 2036 by
which time he will have been at the helm
of russia either as president or prime
minister for a staggering 36 years and
he'll be well into his 80s
so i mean vladimir putin himself has
made it very difficult for anyone to
countenance a russia without him and
that in itself makes the whole situation
very uncertain and makes
all of the discussions about what comes
after him even more perilous because no
one can imagine as you said
russia without putin and some of his if
his advisers have even said there is no
russia without putin
so he is the person who has created this
situation of of uncertainty and of
potential instability because the system
isn't really set up apart from in a more
superficial uh manner for
envisaging a transfer of power
i wonder has he been enabled by the
german chancellor angela merkel she has
been known as the putin whisperer she
also kept nordstrom 2 the pipeline alive
and she refused to push back as
forcefully against an ever aggressive
russia as germany's allies would have
liked how much responsibility does she
carry when we're talking about the
erosion
of the liberal values of democracy that
she has been seen as embodying
well i don't think you can lay the blame
on uh you know putin and his
decision-making on angela merkel i
certainly think that there is a lot of
blame to share in the terms of we needed
a lot more solidarity across europe and
also with the united states to push back
on a number of issues
i think you know right now we see with
the energy crisis that's uh facing uh
europe that many of the dark warnings
that have come from the united states
going back to in fact the 1960s when the
united states opposed the prospect of
energy pipelines from the soviet union
to europe uh are now coming to fruition
we always were greatly concerned that
there would be
a lot of potential for the soviet union
then russia to manipulate
the gas market in europe once that
mutual dependency uh came about
and that opportunity is now there uh in
a time of energy shortage and crisis and
we know of course that the russians did
you know manipulate the markets and uh
put on a lot of pressure uh on ukraine
back in 2006. so those warnings have
been there for some considerable period
of time but it really took um a
concerted collective effort by europe to
push back against this not just uh not
just germany or the chancellor and look
and one
symbol uh that is very important is
angela merkel
is leaving power there is going to be a
handover in uh germany that's coming up
whereas you know we've just been talking
about the fact that putin isn't even
brokering or allowing any kind of
discussion about succession or about the
future and is just leaving it you know
to the prospect of him being in power
until 2036. so you know in germany we
actually have an opportunity right now
with the new coalition government and
the naming of a new chancellor new team
to actually show that there is a path
forward and that political change can
happen in a very important large country
yeah that's a very good point to make
you know you became a household
name in the u.s when you testified
during the first impeachment trial of
donald trump in the u.s congress as i
was reading through your book i kept
thinking that this is a book yes about
russia but even more it's a book about
all of us here in the west did i read
that correctly
no it is a book about all of us it's a
it's a book just using my own uh
personal biographic story but it could
be yours and could be others you know in
this kind of long sweep of time we've
had over these last decades all of our
societies have gone through major
periods of change and you know the in in
the book i talk about the the change
from mass manufacturing in a heavy
industry to the no the knowledge economy
and the way that this caused great
dislocation
and uh socioeconomic grievance and then
political outcomes in the rise of
populism because those who are left
behind be that in east germany be that
in the northeast of england where i came
from be that in the midwest in the
united states felt alienated and
disaffected as the economy
society and politics left them behind
and we're just on the threshold of
another major change
and you know this is actually one of the
reasons why we have an energy crisis
because we're on the cusp of trying to
make a change not just into renewables
but into green energy because of the
pressure of climate change and that will
also inevitably lead to people being
left behind unless we have a concerted
effort in the west in particular to
figure out how we make that transition
and how we retrain people it gets back
to education again and give them the
skills and the qualifications for the
new green economy it is inescapable and
it's again it's another of those issues
that's going to cause a lot of political
backlash we see that in germany we see
that in the united kingdom we see that
in the united states and that's why the
book is about all of us because we all
can take some action we all
are you know part of
these societies and democracy is really
all about us it's about how we
uh
get basically pull together to move on
to the next phase and you know take care
of the people around us not just try to
find
political solutions to these larger
problems
it's also about thoughtful and
considerate analysis which you have
given us tonight for which we are very
grateful fiona hill we appreciate your
time and your insights please come back
and talk with us again thank you
thanks so much thank you for having me
thanks